it's true the gays all speaking code so
you normally will never know that we're
plotting the downfall of the sis
hence patriarchy right in front of you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah not so much
but let's talk about the lovely little
minefield that is gay coding in film and
television
normally I expand these out into a much
broader lgbtq+ conversation but the
video I deal with my partner lives on
bisexual tropes also ended up touching
on coding pretty well and honestly trans
and non-binary coding is different
enough that if I ever felt the need to
tackle that I'd probably need to do it
as its own thing so we're gonna stay
pretty much with just gay coding here
part one defining terms so what even is
coding what are words what is thing I
Can Has Cheezburger
topical reference well in storytelling
coding is a series of traits but so to a
character or sometimes even a location
or event but I'm mainly gonna be talking
about characters here where the trait
corresponds to certain real-world groups
or subgroups or at least their traits
that correspond to the pop culture
representation and be common knowledge
societal understandings of those groups
so they're basically narrative shorthand
to instill characteristics through
culturally understood points of
reference a nice simple example of
coding that is that for decades now the
US has given gender coding certain
colors specifically pink and blue pink
is feminine and blue is masculine now
that's not an all-encompassing hard rule
that is always followed which is
actually true of all coding but it's
just a nice easily grasped example that
most people will recognize so that we're
all on the same page about what we're
actually talking about here now that
example also helps illustrate how
arbitrary coding often is because
there's nothing inherently masculine or
feminine about colors but as a society
we just kind of all decided to treat
them that way and even if you personally
think it's nonsense you still recognize
it because you're immersed in the
culture that uses it
now some coding has traceable roots some
coding is deliberately hurtful and much
of coding can become so embedded that
creators and audiences may not even
recognize it as being coding Lindsay
Ellis went into great detail on this
point in her video that she made on the
Netflix film Brite and to steal one of
her observations have you ever stopped
to think about why certain monstrous
races and fantasy stories like say orcs
overs and trolls usually have darkish
skin flat faces prominent brows well
it's because the early establishes
fantasy tropes like j.r.r tolkien gave
them traits along the lines of people
from parts of the world other than
Europe or as Tolkien himself put it the
least
lovely Mongol types for him these traits
were culturally coded as primitive
barbaric and generally other now it
really needs to be emphasized at this
point that coding is not always
intentional either in its initial
establishment or in its continued use
we're not always aware of the roots of
these things so as I talk about this
this is not intended to be passing
judgment on the creators behind the
examples I'm going to be citing I am
talking trends and patterns not trying
to finger wave at individuals talking
about these sorts of things in the past
such as when I did the video on the
barrier gaze trope I often ended up
explaining why the things I was
discussing are a problem that's not
really gonna be the case this time I'm
telling this video to be more just
straight-up educational so you can be
more aware of these things as a creator
or an audience member this isn't a hit
list of movies that did the bad thing
some people are gonna take it as if I am
doing that anyway so let's just get this
sucker properly started keep it gay so
what does gay coding specifically look
like well that actually depends on
whether we're talking about gay coding
for men or gay coding for women but the
fast and dirty answer is that granting
character traits normally associated
with the opposing gender is gay coding
so male character being coded gay may
have a lilt to the way they speak you're
kind of sweet
- their movements a preoccupation with
their appearance distaste for anything
that would be considered unrefined which
might be exemplified by them requesting
a fancy cocktail over a beer there's
also an aversion to physical
confrontations and should the
opportunity present itself a
high-pitched shriek for female
characters of preoccupation with things
like sports working with one's hands a
lack of makeup or much fashion sense at
all preference for beer over gorilla
drinks might be used to exemplify this
for them and a greater willingness to
resort to violence as a way to deal with
confrontation now as I go through this
and start citing specific examples
they're gonna end up being mostly gay
coated males as those tend to be the
clearest instances things can get muddy
when talking gay coded female characters
because popular culture has a weird
relationship with the tomboy archetype
and by and large masculine traits found
in female characters aren't taken to
mean gay with same consistency as
feminine traits and male characters or
to put it another way if a female tomboy
character is shown to be in a straight
relationship people will bite
by contrast feminine traits and men are
almost never applied innocuously and if
an effeminate male character is shown in
a straight relationship the audience
response is gonna be yeah right so I'll
deliberately be focus on more blatant
examples because it makes my point
stronger and splitting hairs over what
counts as coding
you know just slows things down and that
means most of this is gonna be examples
of male characters and cue the
accusations of my stacking the deck who
gets coded when it comes to gang coding
especially the most stereotypical traits
most of the time it's supporting
characters and villains oh man does it
ever come up with villains but stick a
pin in that we'll come back to it part
of why the coding more often happens
with supporting characters is because
not as much time is gonna be spent with
them as the main characters and more
characterization shortcuts is kinda to
be expected now before I start naming
names and pissing everyone off I am
begging you to not confuse gay coded
with
openly gay and indisputably gay
character gay Cody characters are often
not confirmed to actually be gay in fact
in many instances their sexuality is
never addressed at all but they still
carry the coating regardless so here we
go there is quite a bit of gay coding
the pops up an entertainment aimed at
kids cue the moral panic a few examples
would include the cross-dressing
Pleakley from lilo and Stitch the
squeeing clawhauser from Zootopia Lenny
from Shark Tale being all out of place
in the macho world of his family tingle
from The Legend of Zelda games because
of well whatever this is and even the to
male parent dynamic of the lion Kings
Timon and Pumbaa also fun fact pom was
actually modeled on a female warthog not
a male one it's not unique to children's
entertainment by any means but at this
point most entertainment aimed at older
demographics doesn't have to hide behind
coding like it used to I'll kind of be
touching on the reason for that a little
later so I've got to actually go back a
few years for some non children's
entertainment examples to get the ball
rolling there
now the Buffyverse actually gives us two
really solid ones the first one being
Andrew first introduced in Buffy Season
six and also Lorne over on Angel Andrew
is a feminine soft-spoken afraid of
physical confrontation seems to have a
crush on the character of Warren
meanwhile Lauren is so fabulous you
could make the character a drag queen
instead of a demon and the performance
would play just as well without
alteration now yes I am aware that
Andrew would eventually be confirmed gay
in the comic book continuations of buffy
but in the show itself he was only ever
coded that way now there's also the
Curious Case of coda gay but confirmed
straight which is pretty rare especially
with male characters this is because of
what I noted before about I is just not
buying it when gay hooded men are
depicted as straight an interesting
exception is Niles crane from the TV
show Frasier Niles bears all the
hallmarks of gay coding in the Oscar
Wilde well-to-do FOP vein he's well
spoken to the point of being overly
articulate he has a love of fine wine
opera he is a gentle nature
etc etc etc however his romantic pursuit
of Daphne is a near-constant across the
entire run of the show now before anyone
leaves to the conclusion that his
demonstrated heterosexuality disproves
any of my points it should be noted that
other characters thinking Niles is gay
is a running gag throughout the show and
this includes his own brother the title
character so despite repeated
affirmations of Niles's heterosexuality
due to his coding and character traits
the show often felt the need to keep
hanging a lampshade on and going yeah we
know he comes off as pretty gay
fabulous fiends so remember that pin we
snuck into gay coated villains well
times they got that pin and really dig
into those when you start looking at
prominent examples of gay coded
characters you are going to come up with
a lot of villains the reasons for how
this coding trend started should kind of
be obvious but we'll go over it anyway
homosexuality was openly demonized for
longer than I care to calculate so
granting a character traits coded as gay
gave audiences of the past an automatic
reason to be unnerved unsettled or
distrustful of those characters that's
where I begin villains like Joel Cairo
from the Maltese Falcon fastidious
soft-spoken physically weak emotional
and overly concerned with his appearance
or take the villain henchman Leonard
from Hitchcock's North by Northwest
similarly carefully groomed he also
displays a concern for his male employer
that would appear to go beyond just
employment loyalty and he even refers to
the doubts he has about another
character as his woman's intuition so
that's how this kind of coding has been
used in the more classic era of
Hollywood why did it stick around well
part of it as I talked about in my video
on the barrier gauge trope is that these
sorts things are just difficult to shake
off once they're embedded but there's
more to it than that because there's a
bit of a funny thing about gay coded
villains that I think is a bigger factor
for why they have stuck around to this
day they're just more fun when people
say that a film or TV
show has a fun villain more often than
not that means larger-than-life operatic
over-the-top or to put it another way
flamboyant and even a bit camp Disney in
particular has been noted for heavily
leaning into this aspect and to be clear
I don't think this is for any reason
deeper then it makes their villains more
fun like I said I rarely suspect
intention or deliberate agenda behind
these sorts of coatings happening but
anyway real a real quick rapid-fire of
gay coded villains and Disney going
chronologically we've got the overly
groomed Captain Hook the mincing press
John and his servant sir hiss the
theatrical and boisterous Ratigan Ursula
the sea which may be a woman but she was
literally modeled on a drag queen scarf
flounce is about all over Pride Rock
there's the glitter obsessed Ratcliffe
the shade throwing snark of Hades
serving almost as Meg's best worst gay
friend ever and it's continued into
recent fare with the fafa skin candy and
the Fabulous Tama Toa Disney are far
from the only ones to do this it's
actually pretty prominent across the
board so branching out we've got the
likes of Gareth from labyrinth
over-the-top fashion sense the only
human character to break into song
musical theater still often being seen
as being pretty gay then there's the
bulge which isn't really gay coding
strictly speaking but I mean damn 300 AD
Xerxes contrasting his booming voice and
towering figure with makeup jewelry and
a sexual edge to all of his interactions
with Leonidas it's arguable how much gay
coding was at play with the master from
Doctor Who back in the classic era
although he was undeniably camp in the
later years of that initial run but what
is much less arguable as the modern era
in which an official Doctor Who short
referred to the Masters wife as his
beard which if you don't know in the gay
community is what people call a fake
straight relationship used to hide the
fact that the man is gay now that Doctor
Who short is from Steven Moffat who is
the same writer who helped co-create BBC
Sherlock which gave us our gay coded
Moriarty now one could argue that this
is somewhat subversive since his
characters kind of self-aware of his
mannerisms and indeed early on even
implies that it may just be an
affectation but then again that
affectation never really goes away more
straightforwardly Tim Roth's
quintessential thought being taken down
by the traditionally manly Rob Roy in
the film of the same name
also another rare instance of Cody Gabe
who confirms straight we've also got
Stewie Griffin and Roger from Family Guy
and American Dad respectively who's gay
coatings are pretty undeniable though
the villain label might be a bit more
debatable depending on what season
you're watching I could keep going but
in the interest of time let's round it
off with an indie film example to show
it's not just big Hollywood doing this
thing by mentioning the face stealing
Pahlavi Largo in repo the Genetic Opera
and I'd be remiss if I didn't mention
possibly the gayest villain ever put on
screen Necron from the animated 80's
film fire and ice one character who
deserves special closer examination is
the Joker who has been queer coated to
varying degrees over the years as his
obsession with Batman can and has been
portrayed as a kind of twisted crush in
stories like The Dark Knight Returns
plus he flat out grabbed Batman's ass
and a graphic novel called arkham asylum
a series housed on a series earth now
you can and some do argue that something
like that is just to unnerve Batman and
it's not a demonstration of sincere
affection this is an argument that can
also be applied to that part of Skyfall
where Silva comes on to James Bond and
it's an argument I'm even prepared to
buy but it's still a gay coated action
whether it's sincere for the character
or not so I'm counting it it's like how
finding a narrative justification for a
trope doesn't suddenly make it not a
trope it just makes it any more
justified use of that trope so in
quickly coming back to Batman there's
Jim Carrey's obsessive stalker take on
the Riddler and Gotham's version of the
penguin so to finish off this villains
run down in the process of researching
for this I found a surprisingly robust
lineup of gay coded depictions of the
devil like the actual
literal devil this would include red guy
from cow chicken him from Powerpuff
Girls both versions the robot devil from
Futurama and while it's actually
explicit rather than merely coded I'll
just remind everybody of Satan as seen
on South Park bit weird how
stereotypically gay characteristics seem
to graph so easily under the literal
personification of evil hmm coded
protagonists now I said you know the
start of this thing that mostly this
kind of coding happens with supporting
characters and villains and while less
common there are instances of gay coded
characters in lead roles including on
ambiguous heroes now oftentimes gay
coding on lead characters is being used
in a slightly different fashion than it
is with secondary characters or villains
since with the main character we're
gonna spend more time with them so
coding us a narrative shortcut isn't as
necessary and generally the leads you're
not gonna be having the gay equals
off-putting element so how does it
actually work with the lead character
well let's take a look at a few examples
getting the obvious one out of the way
Frodo from the Lord of the Rings whose
relationship with Sam is pretty gay
coated especially with the presence of
Gollum bring in a whole jealousy vibe
for Sam and again this does not mean the
Sam and Frodo were literally lovers only
that the relationship dynamic especially
in the films is taking more cues from
romantic coding than it is from
traditional male bestfriend coding which
is usually far less openly affectionate
I would actually say the single most
prominent lead character to be coded as
gay and never explicitly stated to be
would be Xena Warrior Princess because
it was never confirmed in universe but
by the time the show wrapped up it was
incredibly difficult to interpret her
relationship with Gabrielle's being
anything other than both romantic and
sexual and that was deliberately how the
actors were playing it by the time the
show ended the cold practical reason for
it being subtextual coding instead of
just being text is that it was a 90s
syndicated show and it simply couldn't
get away with saying it outright so it
was either going to be coded or just not
present at all
this is really worth pointing out
because for as much as coding these days
is often seen as a negative for a long
time the only way to have even
implicitly gay characters in the
mainstream entertainment was to do it
through coding now I think I made it
clear way back in my video on fandom
representation and queerbaiting that I
don't feel this is an excuse that flies
anymore but for a while it was simply
the best we could get the other thing
that really stands out of the zine
example is here we have finally a gay
coded one which I haven't really gotten
to talk about in this video I mentioned
near the start that gay coded women they
share crossover features with certain
female character tropes that are not
usually intended to code them as lesbian
now as I said male characters flouncing
about an eyeliner with a limp wrist
basically serves no purpose outside of
gay coding however a woman presented
more masculine may be feeding into a
straight tomboy not like other girls
stereotype or into the common
progression of female action heroes
where they are masculinized over the
course of the story
so a butchy female character can't have
some of these traits for reasons aside
from gay coding unlike when effeminate
traits are given to male characters and
as a result there are much fewer
clear-cut cases where a masculine woman
is clearly being coded as gay however
another case similar to Xena would be
the film fried green tomatoes now it's
laid out a bit more clearly in the book
but even in the film where it's never
explicitly stated that the characters of
ruth and idgie are in a loving lesbian
relationship it's really hard to read it
any other way
so when it comes to queer coded women
unless they're paired with a female
character who would be the partner the
coded traits don't definitively point to
gay which is why in both fried green
tomatoes and Xena
there is a character clearly failing the
partner role with gay male coded
characters there's no
to give them a partner because those
traits don't really get used in any
other way when scar behaves like this
you don't need to give him a male
partner to make the point but with women
being butch just kind of vaguely
indicates gayness and it's sort of
half-hearted wave rather than just
strongly pointing and shouting J'Accuse
this is probably a good place as any
dimension deadpool who's one of those
odd cases as he tends to be in almost
any context you care to talk about it in
men and now in the comics he is much
more explicitly pansexual in the movies
it's a little less clear-cut his
interests his love interest in the films
is a woman and while he flirts with male
characters mostly colossus it could just
easily be him messing with people for
the walls as you know as opposed to any
kind of genuine sign of affection it's
the same issue that came up when I
mentioned the Joker and Moriarty but
just like those two even if he doesn't
mean it and is doing it ironically this
is still gay code of behavior so just as
Deadpool is an exception to many
standard lead character trappings he's
also an exception as one of the very few
gay coded male lead characters in a
story not specifically about sexuality
gay versus just not interested when it
comes to some characters especially lead
ones there's also the question of
whether a lack of discernible interest
in the opposite gender is enough in and
of itself to call it gay coding you see
while compiling the script for this
thing I looked at a lot of lists of
supposedly gay and queer coded
characters and quite a few of the ones
I'd see mentioned on those lists I have
not used as examples here there were
different reasons for that sometimes it
was because the supposed coding I just
felt was flimsy or I didn't know the
context well enough and that that one is
why I'm not touching anime characters in
this video but other times the only
evidence given was the character showing
no interest in the opposite gender this
is where characters like Elsa from
frozen or cusco from The Emperor's New
Groove come up and out refer folks to
the conversation I had a few months back
about asexual representation too
point out that assuming not interested
in the opposing gender automatically
equals gay isn't as safe an assumption
as it might have been in the past though
to be fair many of the examples that
fall under that kind of heading
including the ones I mentioned would
have been produced and released at a
time when most creators probably
wouldn't have known asexual was really
an option so if the coding had an
intended meaning it may well have been
for the character to be read as gay
however and what I'm about to say is a
statement that some folks are gonna beat
me up over we're not obligated to keep
interpreting things exclusively through
the lens of the times in which they were
made
that's not to say we should ignore
topical context but I don't subscribe to
the idea that the mindset from the time
that a piece of art was made is the only
correct way to approach a work I for one
like how things are more open-ended now
in terms of interpretations of art and I
prefer to view even older works in that
light is it an opposition to the
creator's intent and vision yeah
sometimes I'm sure but I'm also a death
of the author type so I just don't care
conclusion it needs to be remembered
that coding is not in and of itself a
bad thing much like the use of narrative
tropes isn't an inherently bad thing and
like tropes the instances where it's
best applied tends to be those where the
creator has some degree of awareness
this usually results in either a
subversion of the coding or a clear
intentional thought-out purpose for it
and that more than anything is kind of
the point of this whole exercise it's
far easier to fall into traps of lazy or
problematic coding if you don't
recognize what any of it means or where
it comes from the point is not don't
code characters as gay the point is
recognize what you're doing and know why
you're doing it because literally every
narrative device every cliche every
trope every overused bit of coding can
be properly applied with justification
as long as you are aware of it because
otherwise it crops up on
intentionally and serves as just another
addition to the pile of stories that
have already done the exact same thing
[Music]
thank you for watching and a huge thanks
to my patreon supporters if you wish to
support this channel and help me
continue to cover my bills there's a
link down in the description plus
there's all those other things down
there as well the usual is the likes the
subscribe whatever you thought about
what we just discussed leave a comment
down there and let's talk about it and
go ahead and click those buttons click
the likes the subscribes the links or
don't you don't have to because at the
end of the day folks or the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]